الدفاعي ضد داعش عباره عن اساس
لتوطيد العلاقه الثنائيه والولايات
المتحده ملتزمه بهذا بدعم
لامن العراق
ودعم المنطقه كامله
اكدت انا ورئيس الوزراء السوداني التزامنا
اليوم وقبل سنوات كان هناك وجود لداعش
يهدد المواطنين واستقرار المنطقه كامله
وردا على ذلك فالولايات المتحده
وتحالف الدولي
قام بالرد على
بالقيام بتعزيز دور الحكومه السياديه
للعراق لمحاربه هذا العدو الارهابي
وسنواصل للاصغاء لشركائنا
ونقف معهم في هذا هذه الحرب وسنواصل
بتحالف الدبلوماسيين والخبراء
المحاربين وكذلك
مسؤولين في بعثه النيتو هنا ونواصل
التنسيق بين حلفائنا
لتنفيذ هذه المهمه معا
وعبر
التحالف الدولي حررنا اكثر من 30 الف متر
مربع من داعش كيلومتر مربع من داعش وكذلك
حررنا العراقيين من طغيانهم قوات الامن
العراقيه بما فيها
الكرديه
حققت انجازتني كبيره في تعزيز قدرات
مكافحه الارهاب اليوم اصبحوا في المقدمه
هذه العمليات ستضمن
تحر داعش وبالتالي
تعزيز عمليه
محارب الداعش وايضا المحافظه على عدم
وصولهم الى شرق سوريا وفي المرافق
الاعتقال
ومخيمات المهجرين في سوريا اتخذنا بعض
الخطوات الولايات المتحده تقف دائما جاهزه
للاستمرار في دعم العراق وكل الدول
تعمل
لاعاده المواطنين العراقيين وبالتطلع الى
الامام فنحن في القوات الامريكيه
مستعدي الموجوده في العراق بدعوه من
الحكومه العراقيه
وتعمل هذه القوات
النصيحه والدعم
هذه مهمه حساسه ويسرنا ان ندعم شركائنا
العراقيين ولكن يجب ان نعمل بشكل امن
لاستمرار في هذه الحرب اود ان اشكر
السوداني وعباسي على التزامهما اليوم
بضمان ان قوات التحالف في العراق
موجوده بناء على دعوه
الحكومه العراقيه
يركز على المهمه وهي هزيمه داعش ونحن هنا
ليس لاي غرض اخر
واي هجمات على قواتنا يمكن ان تقود هذه
المهمه تحدثنا اليوم عن الرؤيه
لشركتنا مع العراق للتخلص من داعش
نواصل ايماننا بان
الدمج دمج العراق مع شركائها في المنطقه
يمكن ان يوفر
الازدهار والامن والاستقرار
لكن جميع شعوب المنطقه اتطلع للمواصله في
التشاور مع شركائنا
العراقيين لتحقيق مصالحهم ولتحسين حياه
الشعب العراقي انا متفائل مستقبل هذه
الشراكه والولايات المتحده تواصل
تعزيز وتوسعه هذه العلاقه لدعم الاستقرار
والسياده العراقيه مره ثانيه
لرئيس الوزراء سوداني وعباسي وزير الدفاع
من الجميل ان نعود مره ثانيه الى العراق
شكرا لكم جميعا